The Joe Rogan Experience so in the
beginning like when I first met you uh
today rather when I ran into you oh
first thing I was saying I was like are
you still on cloud nine like what is
this like like you you know it was Matt
Sarah and GSP that was like the biggest
upset ever in the history of sport right
but this is like I think this is their
or bigger it might be bigger yeah I mean
I that wasn't my era I'm in the new
generation yeah this is my era so of
course to me it's it's the biggest but
it was huge because Amanda was
terrifying like everybody was scared of
her and you were the one that wasn't
scared of her yeah no you can't be
you're fighting like I know but it's
still it's like it's the way you did it
yeah was so wild like while it was that
like
because you uh were counting me out the
whole time no I'm laughing because DC
sent me a text and in the video look at
your face very I'm ready I'm very ready
DC sent me a text and uh it was a video
of me and him doing commentary in your
fight he goes bro he goes listen to us
we're just making weird noises because
during the fights like oh
screaming like a little girl it was wild
yeah it was [ __ ] wild you know when
you were standing toe-to-toe with her
and smashing her with the jab in the
middle of the Octagon we were like
gripping each other we were like oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] it was it you can't describe
what that's like to watch because it's
like you can't it's hard to believe that
it's happening I felt like if you had a
chance to beat her it would be in a
scramble you would catch her and submit
her yeah grapple exchange wear her down
and submit her but to see you standing
in the middle of octagon and smashing
her with a jab it was like
it was crazy it was so wild to see it
was almost like the world changed yeah
like the whole world changed like what
is not possible is now possible yes well
there's there's two things first is
um there's Styles we've already talked
about that Styles makes fights but I
knew stylistically that I have the
perfect uh style of fighting to beat her
and because there's for example people
I'm not the type to run around the ring
the whole time and do the point sparring
thing and go to the decision it's like
one of us is coming out of here and
that's it that's just the way that my
fighting style is I'm the type where
it's like if there's a big puncher the
only way to meet that is meet fire with
fire and I have to stand in the pocket
so I'm not the type of person to run
away in the fight I'm the type of person
to meet that fire head on right and
match it with my own fire and I knew
that that was how I was going to win and
so that's pretty much all I did is just
game plan that specific type of you're
gonna be in the pocket you're going to
have to meet this fire and you
absolutely cannot shy away from it well
you said it leading up to the fight that
you're gonna drown her yeah
I mean I've been calling for this fight
for five years everyone's like this
girl's talking all this crap you know
she's this and she's that and getting
upset at me like but I've been calling
for this fight since I won uh katzingano
at UFC 200. she beat Misha that night I
beat cat cat had just recently beat her
and in the press conference Amanda's
saying uh that I'm next and then Rhonda
got to cut the line and you know Rhonda
had just got knocked out by Holly Holm
and instead of her you know having to
fight somebody else she got an immediate
title shot and she got to cut the line
and I was like that was my fight she's
the champ said that I was next and so
Rhonda came in she got knocked out and
then I you know I got put to the back of
the line again but I was constantly
saying even when Rhonda was champ and I
won The Ultimate Fighter I kept saying I
want to fight Rhonda I want to fight
Ronda and they wouldn't they wouldn't
give me that fight but the fact that she
knocked out Rhonda helped your fight it
really did when you finally got her yeah
because she's a legend by then true
because before then she was super
dangerous everybody was very aware that
Amanda was like super [ __ ] dangerous
yeah and a vicious knockout artist but
being Rhonda the way she did put her on
the world map right when she knocked
around in 48 seconds everybody's like
holy [ __ ] right you know and your your
fight with her was bigger because of all
the delays like it because she achieved
this goat status six years I think yeah
she's been unbeaten just knocking
knocking people out for like the last
six years so the fact that she knocked
out cyborg like that too incredible
right and then you just stood right in
the [ __ ] pocket yeah
I know and that's great is if I can get
people emotionally invested in me
whether it's in my successes or in my
losses whatever it is as long as you're
watching and as long as you're you know
gripping your seat at the end of your
seat and freaking out I want to invoke
that emotion in people and that's why I
love fighting I think is because you
know whether you're invested in the loss
of the success you're you're watching
and you're like feeling some type of way
and your heart's you know going through
your throat and and to get that reaction
from people and to see the you know
um outpour of people reaching out to me
and how I made them feel it was like it
almost made me feel guilty in a sense
I'm like really yeah my dad lost 15
pounds like this guy's throwing up you
know people are like putting you know
that this guy's like putting um you know
pissed off that they lost all this money
you know and then there's people that
are like super happy but like the
emotions of like people close to me is
seeing how much I put them through I'm
like I'm sorry I did that to you guys
you know like it makes me feel bad you
know I'm like oh man I'm really putting
these people through the ringer like I
feel I feel guilty you know that's
hilarious well listen they're all
invested now yeah you know after that
fight everybody's invested yeah that was
one of the best fights I've ever seen
thank you in terms of like like what do
you want out of a fight you want to you
you want to be completely immersed in
the world goes away all you're thinking
about is what's happening right in front
of you and because of your effort
because of what you accomplished that
night you changed the way people think
about what's possible and not possible
that's everything we want from a fight
everything you were the underdog you
came in you were counted out by so many
people you fought the greatest of all
time and you [ __ ] her up yeah and the
way you did it like the whole world
everybody that watched that was like
holy [ __ ] the world is a different place
now yeah it just goes to show you how
strong the mind is and how you know it's
going to sound corny but my mom always
used to tell me you can do anything you
set your mind to what is next do you
think a rematch is next absolutely
there's still naysayers out there
there's still people that think it was a
fluke there's still people that are
harassing me there's still people that
are like being like she's gonna kill you
you know they're like 10 seconds in your
day that you know and so I I just I
would love nothing more than to to put
the naysayers to bed for one last time
oh yeah yeah now have you guys started
discussing when and if that can happen
yes
um and you know in my mind in a perfect
world July 4th yeah July 4th okay yes
yes let's do it yes yes I totally would
love to find Vegas biggest card
um in my mind uh I would always want
I've always wanted to anyway since I was
on The Ultimate Fighter I would love to
coach The Ultimate Fighter I just you
know the last time that we were supposed
to coach before this fight she she
decided not to do it and and so I'm just
trying to coax her into doing it you
know like come on let's coach shieldsman
fighter and then we'll fight in july
it'll be perfect that would be great
yeah so that in a perfect world that's
how it would be for me but I would
anticipate sometime in the summer for
the rematch The Ultimate Fighter what
kind of a commitment is that it's like a
six-week commitment yeah something like
that it's it is like a six-week
commitment so you just live in Vegas for
six weeks yeah bring your kids good yep
trading there and then Coach people yeah
now um that is always like traditionally
been a way that people have been able to
like get rivalries Really Cooking yeah
because then you're next to each other
all the time for six weeks it just
bubbles up yeah what do you think that's
going to be like being around her for
six weeks you know it
against her personally I think that
she's great you know
um and if I were to be on the show I can
pretty much guarantee you I'm not going
to be pulling any shenanigans
if she pulled the shenanigans then it's
on you know what I mean but like I'm not
out to you know be vicious or malicious
or anything like that
um but again like I said like if I get
pushed in that direction that's a
different story but yeah it's I've seen
Pat like I think the Conor McGregor won
where he was like poking at Uriah it's
just hilarious epic like well how about
when Rhonda was on with Misha she uh
beat her in a competition gives it a
fingers it's so angry oh yeah and I was
right there next to her when they were
at the Red Rock and Misha's like she's
like you can't even throw punches and
Ron is like she stormed off so angry she
went and got admin and they came back
and like I thought they were gonna throw
down right then and there literally like
it was it was awkward well you get to
see sides of people's personality when
you see them on these exchanges with
each other right remember Rashad Evans
and Rampage yes and like you a [ __ ]
treat me like a [ __ ] you're a [ __ ]
treat me like a [ __ ] like face to face
with each other but like several seconds
yes saying that yeah or even like
vonderley and Chelsea oh That's a
classic yeah they straight up spot yeah
that's a classic I I would hope like you
know that that wouldn't be the case you
know like let's be adults about this but
then it that's the flip side it's like
we're trying to sell the fight right
we're trying to make people invested and
make sure that they watch the fight so
it's like how can it be you know this
Epic season of The Ultimate Fighter
without that kind of chaos but it's like
Amanda's not that kind of person and I'm
not either yeah I don't think it has to
be that way look the fight is gonna be
giant no matter what right when you guys
have a rematch holy [ __ ] God it better
be in North America the other thing that
was interesting about that fight was her
last two fights before that Megan
Anderson and Cyborg what was it Megan
answering the Cyber was that were they
back to back I think so in the 45
Division yeah yeah so both of our fights
were at 45 like she hadn't defended 35
in quite a while right two years yeah so
the making that extra 10 pounds it's
probably a big deal like she looked very
lean at the weigh-ins like leaner than
you ever see her before lean and she
showed up all half naked and she was
ready to go she was in the best shape of
her life it looked like she looked
ripped she looks yeah she actually
looked ripped but you know oftentimes
when people haven't cut weight yeah and
then they have to yeah you know that you
see like uh there's a difference in like
where your body bounces back from that
yeah well her focus in her Camp was two
fights I gotta make weight and then I
gotta worry about Juliana my focus was
all I have to do is worry about Amanda
that's it that was my only fight that
was my whole Focus her sole focus is I
gotta be miserable for the next three
months because I got to make weight and
make sure that I'm you know up to par
and me I've been grinding the whole time
so I was like all I gotta focus on is
just her and everybody was aware of the
Kayla fight everybody was aware that
Kayla was in the audience and they were
trying to set that fight up and how dare
they right because uh Kayla is like
talking about how she's training
partners with Amanda and how she learns
so much from Amanda and how Amazing
Amanda is as a training partner and how
you know she has just learned so much
from the champ and so I'm so confused
because you want Amanda to win so that
you can fight your friend
well they just want to get paid yeah
well she's getting paid Millet she's
getting paid more than I am at the uh
making the millions over there at the
pfl I think the idea was that and I'm
just guessing that Amanda you know when
this worldwide recognition is the
greatest woman fighter of all time and
then you get if she beat you then you
get this giant super fight with this
Olympic Judo medalist who seems like you
know when you look at Kayla she seems
like a threat like you go okay well
Amanda's is like super strong like
really good Grappler knockout puncher
Kayla is such an elite judoka she's so
good and she's so [ __ ] strong you you
think oh like that could be a giant
super fight yeah and I think they
probably thought if she came over to the
UFC they would have like the biggest
female fight of all time yeah well I
really messed that up good who needs
friends with who needs enemies with
friends like these you know especially
with Kayla and Amanda being like like
training partners and like hugging each
other and and now they're going to fight
each other like come on it's ridiculous
but if Kayla wants to come over to the
UFC and make weight let's let pack your
lunch 35 you mean 35 45 whatever you
guys want to do yeah at 45. yeah I mean
all I can say like we already
established if it don't make money it
don't make sense and what's the job of a
fighter especially with the window being
this small and your opportunity being
this small I got to jump through a
window this little yeah my job is to
make as much money as possible right so
pay me I'll fight whoever you I'll fight
Fedor pay me just pay me I hear you you
know I feel like I'm not asking for too
much especially now that I'm a champion
I've been saving my silver bullets this
entire time and now that I got it it's
like I want to get paid is that too much
to ask I mean as a professional yeah
don't you feel like you shouldn't of
course there's flip side no one's
holding a gun up to your head no one's
making you fight no but I'm a
professional yeah you know and I'm at
the the height of my game I'm the
Champion I'm at the top of my league you
know pay me also you have a child you
have a future you have to you know you
have a window of opportunity with
fighting that doesn't last very long I
mean it's one of the smallest Windows of
opportunity for an elite professional
athlete I gotta hold on to this little
chunk of money that I have for the rest
of my life you know it's like what do
you I feel like I'm not asking for too
much you know what I mean I just want
what's fair I think if you beat Amanda
again excuse me
when yes at 35 and then you fight her
for the 45 pound title yes that would be
crazy that would be like bullying yeah
well somebody suggested well what if she
uh doesn't decide to take the fight with
you and decides to take an easier fight
at 45 and retires off into the sunset
like she can't she can't do that she
would look like the biggest coward on
Earth
um sometimes people just get worn out by
the pressure too though that's a that's
a factor how hard is it to go do your
road work when you're waking up in silk
pajamas every morning it's Marvin Hagler
you know he's another guy walked away in
his prime yeah good for Marvin good for
Marvin but I mean it's got to be
difficult you're sitting on 10 mil in
the bank it's it's the motivation is
just not there